esta vez tenemos estas cuatro fracciones
y lo que vamos a buscar en este vídeo es
que logremos saber cuáles de ellas son
equivalentes entre sí mismas o cuál es
la más pequeña cuál es la más grande o
como decía así es que hay alguna que sea
idéntica a la otra y lo vamos a hacer de
distintas maneras la primera que
utilizaremos será una recta numérica
así es que dibujaré una recta numérica
lo mas derechita que pueda empezando en
el cero y marcaremos esta recta numérica
no soy muy buena dibujante pero de
verdad esto es en un gran esfuerzo y
marcaremos esta recta numérica hasta el
número uno que que será nuestro primer
entero vamos a utilizar cada una de
estas fracciones y la vamos a llevar a
nuestra recta numérica primero tenemos
un medio eso significa que esta recta
numérica del 0 al 1 será dividida en dos
partes iguales tenemos un medio entonces
pensemos que aquí va la mitad y hablar
de un medio implicaría que hemos
avanzado
una de esas dos partes iguales estamos
de acuerdo
así es que aquí tendríamos nuestro medio
y medio
perfecto ahora vamos a localizar dos
cuartos dentro de la misma recta ahora
esta fracción nos indica que el espacio
o la distancia que se encuentra entre el
0 y el 1 está dividido en cuatro partes
iguales así es que si aquí teníamos dos
partes iguales vamos a dividir esas dos
partes iguales
en otras dos partes iguales
perfecto y nos dice que hemos recorrido
todas de esas cuatro partes iguales así
es que será 1 2 y llegamos exactamente
al mismo punto un medio 2 cuartos
podemos entonces escribir que un medio
es igual a dos cuartos es igual a dos
cuartos representan la misma posición
representan el mismo número sin embargo
las fracciones están puestas de manera
distinta son fracciones equivalentes
vamos a seguir con los cuatro octavos
que tenemos aquí este denominador nos
indica que el espacio o la distancia
entre 0 y 1 está dividido en ocho partes
iguales ya tenemos aquí cuatro vamos a
volver a dividir y tendremos una 2
4 5 6 7 8 partes iguales de las cuales
recorreremos 4 así es que vamos 1 2 3 4
llegamos al mismo punto tenemos entonces
también que cuatro octavos es
equivalente a un medio coloquemos
entonces cuatro octavos
estas tres fracciones son fracciones
equivalentes entre sí y marcan el mismo
número pero representado de distintas
maneras vamos con el último tenemos tres
octavos y ya tenemos nuestra recta
numérica dividida en ocho partes iguales
así es que recorreremos con el color
verde tres de ellas
1 2 3 en este punto se colocarán
nuestros tres octavos y con esto que
podemos decir podemos decir que tres
octavos es un número más pequeño que un
medio que dos cuartos y que cuatro
octavos con la recta numérica podemos
visualizar cuántos de ellos fueron
equivalentes y cuál fue menor o mayor
que si nosotros buscáramos tener esta
misma claridad pero desde una pero desde
un punto visual vamos a tener lo
siguiente y lo que hicimos fue dibujar
las fracciones representadas con los
siguientes cuadros todos y cada uno de
estos cuatro rectángulos tienen las
mismas dimensiones solo que las hemos
dividido en distintas formas de acuerdo
a la fracción que cada uno representa en
este caso tenemos nuestro rectángulo
dividido en dos partes iguales de las
cuales una se encuentra coloreada con
este tono como salmón o rosita así es
que podemos colocar
un medio si nosotros lo comparamos con
dos cuartos vemos que tenemos la misma
cantidad de superficie cubierta con el
mismo color porque tiene sentido que un
medio y dos cuartos sean iguales porque
si nosotros separamos estas dos partes
iguales en otras dos partes iguales
tendríamos lo siguiente
lo ven es exactamente la misma
superficie tendríamos entonces dos
cuartos del rectángulo coloreado con
este tono rosita vamos a ver si dos
cuartos son equivalentes con cuatro
octavos y de hecho si tiene sentido si
nosotros dividiéramos estos cuatro
espacios en ocho tendríamos algo así
donde tendríamos 1 2 3 4 de la misma
manera que aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 sólo que
están acomodados digamos intercalados si
nosotros reordena damos estos cubos nos
daríamos cuenta que es exactamente la
misma superficie y lo ven
y finalmente tenemos tres octavos porque
estos son distintos porque nosotros aquí
tendríamos cuatro de esos octavos y aquí
sólo tenemos tres si buscáramos que
fueran equivalentes hubiésemos
necesitado colorear este cuarto espacio
sin embargo no es el caso así es que
podemos concluir que un medio es igual a
dos cuartos que es igual a cuatro
octavos
o como podemos llamarle son fracciones
equivalentes mientras que tres octavos
es un número menor a estas fracciones
equivalentes nos vemos en otro vídeo